hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
ac.l2.3.1.10 use session lock with
pattern hiding displays to prevent
access and viewing of data after period
of inactivity
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all the cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliant stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you've
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in
cmmccontrolac.l
2-3.1.10 sounds like a secret code to
get into a Speak Easy uh we're made
we're mandated to make sure that if
someone else might somehow be viewing
our screen while typing in a password
that they could not easily view what our
password might be great example of this
is your shoulder surfing that is someone
is walking by and grabs your password
while you're typing it in uh or even in
a screen sharing session right you gotta
type in a password to help the tech
support representative in regards to
Define period of inactivity piece this
is easily accomplished with login
timeouts and screen lock timeouts after
a certain number of minutes of
inactivity which course would indicate
perhaps nobody's really sitting at the
keyboard anymore that's how you would
get it done
now if I was assessing you there are
three points that I have to assess you
based off of first I've got to determine
if the period of inactivity after which
the system initiates a session lock is
defined now what's the answer to that if
I was giving a sample answer I would
definitely notate the screen lock
timeout policy maybe you want to set the
five minute three minutes maybe it needs
to be 15 minutes whatever it may be a
screen lock timeout policy will
definitely turn help you to lock them
out after that period of inactivity
make sure a password is required Point
number two I'm going to assess you on
determine if access to the system and
viewing of data is prevented by
initiating a session lock after the
defined period of inactivity
and if we were to give an answer that we
might say yes policy is enforced and
demonstrated and linked right we want to
make sure that group policy we mentioned
above is actually enforced and the final
third assessment point is I would
determine if previously visible
information is concealed via a pattern
hiding display after the defined period
of activity again I would say yes it is
after a screen lock occurs typing in a
password will result in character input
being massed that's those little dots
that show up when you type in your
password that's the masking and hey uh
if you are struggling figuring this
stuff out you're not alone I promise
you're not alone okay like literally
hundreds of calls a day and on call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this dfars nist itar
and cmfc compliance stuff dropped in
their lap like a single on a sunny day
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
becoming that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance.com
Com or check out the bio below for links
to get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out there for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance service roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friend stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign